[Music]
we're going to paul and denver what's up
paul how are we doing
good how are you man we are we are
rocking onto the break of dawn brother
all right huh so what's up man
so let's kind of get straight straight
to it um so my wife and i have been
married for about 12 years
after the first year and a half she had
an affair
we ended up getting a divorce
within about three months of finding out
uh but then
we were young ended up working things
out went through counseling
i got remarried
fast forward a few few years later
while i was at work she packed up the
packed up the kids went to a family
member's house
she was only gone for a couple weeks
got back into counseling started working
on our marriage ourselves
work things out
and then about two years ago
i found out that while she was gone
for those couple of weeks
she had
been going on a couple of dates with a
guy that she had worked with
or was was working with at the time
and that's
i found out about that two years ago
but that all took place about five years
before i found out
um
you have a threat of mistrust your
relationship's built on a lack of trust
huh
yeah 100
you know and then there's there's been
financial
trust issues
yeah uh right before i found out about
this
i found out that she had credit cards
that i didn't know about she had
borrowed money from family members to
pay the credit card so i didn't find out
about it
it's just it's kind of been
one thing after another
so
i guess my question is
i feel like i've i've forgiven her
for a lot of it i feel like i've said a
lot of it down
i mean i still think about it obviously
sure
but
in return
over the last couple of years i have
felt
more emotionally and physically
disconnected from her sure um
she lies to you and cheats on you man
your feelings are valid brother
yeah like
yeah you're yeah you're right where you
need to be man this is a hard situation
yeah
um so i guess i'm just trying to figure
out how to move forward because
you know i i we've got two kids that's
kind of watching us we don't fight we
don't argue um
you know we say we love each other we
hug we kiss we you know we i guess put
on a front if you will
um
and
just trying to figure out how how how
can i either get my marriage back on
track or when
when do you call it enough man
brother paul thanks for calling man
this is a hard phone call for you isn't
it
uh yeah more than you know yeah
because i'm
one of those kind of macho guys i don't
talk about stuff but that's right i am
too bro
like you're you're a brave guy i
appreciate you calling dude
um i know i can tell in your voice you
don't have this conversation very often
with very many people and so uh it's an
honor and i'm grateful for the call man
and for what it's worth you're gonna
help a whole whole bunch of people
who are in the exact same situation
you're in so
um bravery's got a ripple effects that
can change hearts and and legacies of
people you'll never meet brothers so
thank you so much
um
so let's back up high five to you for
using the word set it down
for deciding i'm gonna forgive her i'm
not gonna poison myself
because she made some bad decisions
and
you've recognized hey man i was young
and immature i'm sure you contributed to
mess inside your home she's done some
uh had some major integrity issues and
some violations i'm sure there was some
give and take all through this thing is
that fair over the last 12 years oh
absolutely all right absolutely so um
one of the things that's hard when
somebody cheats on you or somebody is
dishonest with you is you got to look in
the mirror and say did i create an
environment where somebody could be safe
doesn't excuse what they did but it's
good to look in the mirror and be
reflective and say what did i contribute
to this thing
did i set up a world where she had to go
hide money because i blew up or i
hoarded all the money or fill in the
blank right
so let's fast forward to now
you've been to counseling a few times
you got divorced you gave another shot
you got remarried
and now you find yourself in a situation
where you're being the one that's not
honest
where you are playing
husband you're playing
love
and man you are two inches apart but
2000 miles away from that woman is that
right
yeah yeah
so something about you thinks you are
worthy of a woman who cheats on you and
worthy of a woman who lies
and puts your financial health at risk
and
is setting a pretty dismal example for
your kids what is it about you brother
that makes you think how's this kind of
the way this is
honestly i don't know um i think i've
kind of just held on to everything that
uh
everything that we've been through i
guess in the past and the fact that i
know
uh you know i contributed to a lot of
the
um
not necessarily cheat cause that's one
thing that i i've never
never been i mean i don't i don't agree
with it but
um
i contributed a lot to pushing her away
i guess throughout the years whether it
was
working
drinking going out with friends
maybe talking down to her at some point
i'm sure
so
i kind of hold on to that to say maybe
it's my fault i guess which is
kind of sounds stupid in a way no i mean
it's not stupid brother you're i mean
you're taking ownership you're being
reflective that's what being a wise
adult who's wants to heal his life you
know what i mean so
i mean that's not stupid at all
it doesn't give somebody license to
continually abuse you
and
it doesn't give license for somebody to
lie and put your your physical health at
risk to put your financial health at
risk and put your children's health at
risk
um
because you've messed up too we all have
we've all said things we wish we could
take back and we've all fill in the
blank
the real the real question we come to
right now is this
what do you want to do
you feel stuck and i want to take the
walls off you can snap your fingers what
would you do
be done
yeah i mean like yeah
say it out loud
say it out loud
i think i would be done um if
if what
i start thinking about my kids and my
kids future and and i got that i got
that here's the thing
your kids are absorbing that
disconnection they're absorbing the fake
relationship
and they can't put their finger on it
but they know
and my guess is you grew up in a house
like that too
yeah you'd be right
and so your your kids are going to
absorb it and that's what they're going
to know they're not going to know two
people who are madly in love with each
other and who
have disagreements and who come back to
the table and come back to the table and
who are connected in their own weird
ways they're gonna know performance
they're gonna know hug at the right
moment and
pursed lips pet kiss at the right moment
and then dad goes upstairs or down in
the basement and grabs a beer and then
mom gets on her phone
that's what their picture of marriage
and love is going to look like
and if y'all are willing to both get in
and root that out awesome
but you don't trust this woman and she
hasn't been trustworthy and my guess is
she doesn't trust you either
and that is a recipe for ash
it's fair
yeah
did she trust worthy now has she changed
uh yeah i mean i i would say she's a
completely different person um just the
way she carries herself
the way that she acts how involved she
is
um
you know you've given me a bunch of
performance attributes can you trust her
yeah i mean i think that height does she
love being honest with you
yeah
okay sorry i cut you off man be honest
with me
um
yeah i do trust her i i do um
but there's there's there's that doubt
right yes because i trusted her before
and i was always that person that said
that uh um
you know she was one of the most honest
pretty people i've ever met in my life
and she was in my face yeah well and
here's where it blows up in your face
man
because you don't trust you now
yeah you don't trust her but you don't
trust yourself either you don't trust
yourself to not snap you don't trust
yourself to
not hide to not stay out too late not to
have one too many drinks you don't trust
yourself
to
pick the right girl
and until paul starts trusting paul
again
paul's not gonna be able to trust
anybody
are you a good dad
yeah
have you changed too as a husband
yeah
so why don't you forgive paul
you haven't forgiven you yet man
are you worthy
how do you do that
you write yourself a letter dear
paul i'm sorry
i'm sorry that i wasn't the husband that
i wanted to be i'm sorry that
contributed to mess in this home i'm
sorry that i don't trust myself anymore
i'm not sorry that i gave my wife a
second and third and fourth chance and
i'm not sorry that i'm trying to be a
great dad but i'm sorry that i lost
trust in you and that ends today
and then over the next two months three
months six months when those moments of
self-doubt
creep in you have somebody that you're
gonna call or somebody you're gonna text
or you stand up and say nope paul you're
a good dad and you're a good husband
and what happens is you practice that
kind of language to yourself you stop
talking to paul
in ways that you would never let
somebody else talk to your neighbor
but you forgive paul
and when you forgive paul you can
continue to forgive your wife or
you can set that brick down that you're
not good you're not good enough this is
what you deserve and you can demand
better
when's the last time you just fell
asleep at night
and slept hard without any
sleep anything without a couple of beers
you just went to sleep
it's been a while when's the last time
you and your wife got to laughing so
hard your guts hurt and then y'all ended
up making out and it was awesome
i couldn't tell you that exactly
listen to me very carefully
your life is worth that
you paul are worth that that's called
joy it's called peace
is the last time somebody cut you off in
traffic and you just started laughing
instead of gripping the wheel so tight
the last time a politician said
something stupid and you rolled your
eyes instead of your heart rate going up
that's peace brother
and you deserve that
here's here's what here's just as guide
a guy here's let me tell you
you're not crazy for not wanting to put
your hand back in the bag when you know
there's a rattlesnake in there you've
been bit a few times that's okay you're
not a bad husband you're not a bad guy
you're not crazy you've been cheated on
you've been you've experienced financial
infidelity you've been cheated on
several times quite a few times actually
you're not crazy for having that little
voice in the back of your head
your wife has to understand that
that's part of healing
you also
have to ask for forgiveness and you got
to forgive yourself if you haven't
already that's the next step for you
brother is you're going to sit down with
your wife and say i'm going to ask you
to forgive me
and all you can control is you your
thoughts and your behaviors and so from
this point forward from today on you can
start talking to paul as though he's a
man of character a man of integrity and
a dad doing the best he can
and a husband doing the best he can do i
have your word on that brother
absolutely you'll start treating paul
with respect
yep okay
and then here's the only way forward man
is you and your wife go somewhere and
you sit down and you look each other in
the eye and you you lay it all on the
table
i'm struggling we are not connected
we're playing house
and i want to dream about what this
marriage could look like
and then we're going to we're going to
pick the town and the home
and we're going to backfill it
reverse engineer it here's what it would
look like
every day to wake up and say i love you
we're gonna hold hands for five minutes
30 seconds
i will put a note on the mirror in our
bathroom every single day seven days a
week for the next six months next two
months
i will ask you what i can do to help you
out today and she will ask you what she
can ask you i mean what she can do to
help you
we're going to get that granular and
we're going to decide to begin to
practice desire we're going to decide to
practice dating each other again we're
going to decide that when negative
thoughts come up i'm going to be open
about them i'm going to be honest about
them and if you have those moments where
you think
oh man i didn't remember her having that
purse and then boom the alarms go off
that she's borrowing money or taking
money again
you get to ask hey are we still in the
up and up financially and she's going to
say yeah baby i'm with you
when she's out too late or she's
checking her phone a lot and kind of
hiding it you get to ask
hey are we still connected one-on-one
you're still with me right she can say
yep i'm still with you
you're gonna practice this thing step by
step by step and along the way you're
gonna teach your kids what marriage and
love and connection and forgiveness
and gritty reality of it looks like and
you can look up two years five years ten
years and you're going to be a ninja
couple
or you're gonna get four months in and
say hey i'm not i'm out
but you can't do marriage halfway
you got to be all in or you got to be
out
what are you what are you going to be
man
man can hurt my feelings either way i'm
going home to my wife my on my own
you all in are all out
i'm gonna go all in um
and i feel like i i feel like i'm saying
i'm going all in but i still got the
the reality that i'm not gonna be all in
or feel like i'm not gonna be all in
um
yeah i don't know a lot it is
paul going all in doesn't mean
your radars are not still up going
all-in doesn't mean you're naive and
idiotic
going all in says i'm going to be honest
intentional and direct and we're gonna
practice this thing until the ship turns
around
that's what that means going all in says
i'm gonna stop beating myself up all the
time all the time all the time
i'm gonna forgive paul
if i have to say sorry to my kids i'm
gonna say sorry to my kids
if i got other people in my life i gotta
say sorry too i'm gonna say sorry to him
i'm gonna write myself a letter i'll do
it every day
you're gonna do something really tough
really hardcore paul get a journal and
write to yourself
it's easy to lift weights and to talk
crap at a bar it's really hard to be
honest with yourself
that's brave that's strength that's hard
do
that make the commitment either in or
out
an end doesn't mean you're going to
stumble you won't fall down you won't
screw up you won't have bad thoughts in
just means i'm in
have that conversation take your wife
out to breakfast so y'all go have this
hard conversation
something tells me she's wrestling with
this too
she's either halfway out the door or she
misses you
like the sun and the moon and the stars
my brother
somebody's gotta turn the lights on and
make a call
your move brother